en una Rusia empeñada en el
expansionismo recordar a un hombre que
propició la caída de la unión soviética
es un ejercicio complicado
quería creer sinceramente que la guerra
fría terminaría y llegaría a un eterno
período romántico entre la nueva Unión
soviética y el mundo
ese Romanticismo no estaba justificado
pero para los críticos de gobierno de
Vladimir Putin gorbachov representa algo
más
el disidente encarcelado adexe y navalni
siente lo que él llama un triste respeto
por el líder fallecido el hecho de que
hoy la gente como yo se entere de su
muerte por los altavoces de sus celdas
caracteriza perfectamente la
transformación de mi país iniciada por
este hombre excepcional la visión de
Beijing la de un hombre que ayudó a
mejorar las relaciones entre vecinos
el señor gorbachov contribuyó
positivamente la normalización de las
relaciones entre China y la unión
soviética
expresamos nuestras condolencias por la
muerte de corbachov y el pésame a su
familia
en Europa y especialmente en un país
como Alemania fracturado por la Guerra
Fría corbachov es el hombre que unió a
un continente
no olvidaremos que la perestroika hizo
posible en el intento de establecer la
democracia en Rusia y que la democracia
y la libertad se hicieron posibles en
Europa
Alemania pudo unificarse que la cortina
de hierro desapareció el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden hizo Eco De
este sentimiento al elogiar el icono
soviético como un líder excepcional que
hizo el mundo un lugar más seguro y el
británico Boris Johnson hizo un
comparativo con el actual liderazgo Ruso
y lo que me preocupa hoy en día es que
los actuales dirigentes de Moscú están
empeña deshacer Lo bueno que hizo mijail
gorbachov y están empeñados en un
intento revanchista un intento
revanchista de recrear aquel imperio
soviético tal vez debido a este
contraste de ideologías la agencia de
noticias rusa interfaz informó que
gorbachov no recibirá un funeral de
estado